d'intro del bosque est dans la forêt
c'est là que l'artiste veut emmener les
visiteurs a traversé son installation
aux multiples entrées comme ses tableaux
luz severino invite chacun à
s'interroger sur la place de l'homme
dans la nature et le drame qui se
déroule sous ses yeux tous les choses
que c'est parce que je voudrais y avait
les planètes allait chauffer les planes
taquet volley ball les la folie qui
disparaît à cause des fautes c'est c'est
normal je suis très attaché à la nature
j'adore la nature qui protège beaucoup
je vais donner ou une réflexion dans la
société délivre pas mon frère
l'attention c'est notre avis va mal et
protéger la force d'une heure et de
transmettre une émotion un message est
parfois une énergie ce matin beaucoup
d'amateurs d'art sont touchés d'une
façon très personnelle mais forcément
sent une énergie et puis alors il ya des
ces arbres blanc génie tout alors qu'il
me faisait penser au cap 110 au mémorial
cap 110 avec ses statues de l'artiste a
fait et qui sont vraiment
impressionnantes et kaki et je me suis
promené une fois dont parmi ses statuts
et j'en ai pleuré parce que je
ressentais quelque chose de très fort et
ses arbres là me font un peu la même
impression
ils nous disent attention regarder
autour de nous il ya encore possibilité
de sauver la terre de sauver la planète
de nous sauver nous mêmes dans les
oeuvres de luz severino l'homme comme
les arbre prend racine dans le sol et
s'élèvent vers le ciel
cette verticalité présente dans chacune
de ses créations invite à s'interroger
pour luz
la verticalité c'est la façon dont on
est en contact avec le sol donc une
terre nourricière à la fois pour la
végétation et puis notre stabilité pour
nous en tant qu'homme et puis cette
relation qu'on peut avoir avec l'espace
est allé jusqu'au ciel voilà elle le dit
et c'est ce qui ponctuent toute cette
exposition avec ses armes
luz severino partage la fiche avec
habdaphaï à la fondation clément
jusqu'au dimanche 24 novembre